Hoy vamos a hablar de un tema realmente
interesante hoy nos vamos a acercar
hasta la revolución de las rosas un
proceso político que consiguió que en
muy poco tiempo
todo un país pasase de sentirse
orgulloso de ser la tierra natal de
Joseph Stalin
a honrar a ronald reagan
Así es, Enrique, Georgia
ha protagonizado el proceso de reformas
políticas y económicas más ambiciosos
de los últimos 50 años. Ni Singapur, ni
Corea del Sur, ni Irlanda realizaron tantos
cambios en tan poco tiempo
hoy vamos a verlo
Georgia es un pequeño país a orillas del
Mar Negro cuya historia se remonta hasta
el año 700 antes de Cristo
Y ya desde el siglo XI es un estado unificado
como hoy lo conocemos su elemento más
característico es, sin duda, su idioma
y sobre todo su alfabeto, el alfabeto georgiano, que es utilizado por menos de
cinco millones de personas en todo el
mundo y que a nosotros nos puede resultar
realmente extraño
sin embargo nuestra
historia comienza el día 9 de abril de
1991, el día en que Georgia se
independizó de la extinta Unión
Soviética (URSS)
Fue en ese momento cuando los habitantes de
este país tuvieron que recordar
preguntas que habían permanecido en el
olvido por más de 70 años: ¿qué producir?
¿cómo producir? y ¿a quién vender?
Además este pequeño país y vio como
sustituciones se desmoronaban por
completo y en apenas unos meses sufrió
un derrocamiento de un gobierno,
el regreso al poder de un antiguo
jerarca de la unión soviética, el
fracaso militar de su ejército en la
sublevación de Osetia del Sur y un
estallido armado en la región de Abjasia
donde 250.000 gergianos sufrieron una
auténtica persecución étnica.
Cuatro años después de la
independencia, su producto interior bruto
se había desplomado un 78%.  La
corrupción, el crimen organizado y el
régimen autoritario del presidente Shevardnadze se hicieron con el poder
Y de esta forma llegamos a 2003, año en el
que se produce la Revolución de las Rosas
Pero antes de empezar a hablar de ella creo que sería
importante destacar dos personajes claves
de este acontecimiento
Por un lado el personaje saliente Eduard
Shevarnadze, quien llevaba más de 30 años
controlando prácticamente Georgia
Curiosamente la actividad política
de este hombre se enmarca más fuera de
Georgia que dentro porque fue nada más y
nada menos que Ministro de Asuntos Exteriores
de la URSS (1985-1991), la mano derecha
de Gorbachov y uno de los impulsores de la
Perestroika.
luego tenemos por otro lado el personaje
entrante Mihail Saakashvili abogado de
prestigio en Estados Unidos, quien
comenzó curiosamente su carrera
política de la mano de Eduard Shevardnadze
Sí, y es
que Mihail Saakashvili fue ministro de
justicia con este hombre, pero la verdad es
que no acabaron nada bien su relación
porque siendo ministro quiso impulsar una
ley que perseguía fervientemente la
corrupción hasta tal punto que si al
que no podía probar de donde había
obtenido un bien, si no podía pobrar su
origen el estado
iba a embargar ese bien
Pues la verdad es
que la oligarquía no aceptó de
buen grado esa propuesta y se le
rechazó
Tras este desencuentro Saakashvili abandona el gobierno de Shevardnadze e inicia su posición
política al mismo, llegando a los
comicios de noviembre 2003 con un
respaldo social importante
Sin embargo, contra toda encuesta contra todo pronóstico
los resultados oficiales señalan como
ganador a Shevardnadze.
Saakashvili no los compra, habla de fraude democrático y
sale a la calle junto a sus simpatizantes
llegando a tomar incluso el día 22 del
mismo mes el hemiciclo durante la
primera votación del mismo
Tras este incidente, tras este
acontecimiento, Shevarnadze decide
renunciar a la presencia de gobierno y
convocar nuevas elecciones.
Curiosamente en febrero de 2004 se repiten las y
las elecciones y Saakashvili obtiene un
apoyo de más del 96% contando
entre sus votantes
curiosamente con Shevardnadze incluso.
Con semejante apoyo no es extraño que el
gobierno de Saakashvili puediese sacar
adelante como antes comentaba Alberto
un plan de reformas realmente intenso,
reformas que pueden clasificarse en tres
puntos principales: el primero de ellos
-el que a mí más me gusta- la
liberalización de la economía.
Empezando por cambiar el sistema fiscal
pasando de un sistema farragoso
con muchísimos impuestos a un sistema con
sólo seis impuestos con tipos bajos y
además muy simple que se podía resumir
en cuatro folios. Cuando los impuestos son
bajos y además son fáciles de pagar la
evasión fiscal pierde su sentido pues el
gobierno de Saakashvili consiguió
bajando impuestos recaudar en pocos
años seis veces más dinero, multiplicó
la recaudación por seis con lo cual
había más dinero para educación,
sanidad
El segundo punto fue enmendar la
constitución e introdujeron la denominada "Ley
Libertad": el gasto público quedaba limitado
un 30% del PIB y ojo lo
más importante
cualquier subida de impuestos tenía que
ser aprobada por la ciudadanía
mediante referendum, que eso en españa
con Montoro no lo hemos tenido
desgraciadamente y a mí me parece
fenomenal que la gente pueda opinar
directamente
El segundo punto, clave también en todo este
proceso, fue la privatización de
empresas públicas, privatizaciones además
mediante subasta de tal forma que
cualquier persona de Georgia o
extranjero puediesen comprar los activos
públicos
De hecho hay una anécdota y es que la
primera empresa privatizada por el
gobierno fue un complejo turístico en
la ciudad de Batumi, un oligarca local
acostumbrado a comprar cosas públicas
le ofreció al gobierno 80 mil dólares y
Saakashvili dijo NO, lo sacó a subasta y
obtuvo más de 3 millones de euros
El último punto de la reformas: combatir la
corrupción y reducir el peso del estado,
la dimensión del estado, pues con
todo esto saakashvili cambió por
completo el panorama de Georgia y lo
convirtió en una de las economías más
libres del Cáucaso y a niveles
prácticamente occidentales y, con ello,
llegó prácticamente la prosperidad. No está mal, ¿verdad? Siete añitos.
Bueno hay que decir también que Enrique es un poco forofo de Saakashvili
y bueno no es oro todo lo que reluce
este hombre también tiene sus lados
oscuros por ejemplo en 2008 para
terminar con la sublevación de la
región de Osetia del Sur no dudó en
atacar y hacer uso de las armas
Dio una
excusa a Rusia
nada justificable pero desde luego
ya sabemos cómo es Putin y entró con
todo su peso, invadió Georgia sino que
también sé destruyeron
infraestructuras claves para el país
pues la verdad es que al final el
balance fue bastante negativo
También otro epidosio bastante oscuro fue en 2007
en las elecciones paradójicamente alguien
que había llegado al poder
tratando de denunciar un fraude democrático
pues parece que no fueron del todo
limpias por su parte
Y su  situación
actual es ya de película porque ahora
mismo
Saakashvili no es ciudadano georgiano, ha
renunciado a su nacionalidad, ahora mismo
es ucraniano y es gobernador de una
región de Ucrania nada más y nada
menos. La justicia de Georgia le busca
desde luego daría para una miniserie
Todo eso que cuentas es verdad Alberto,
pero yo es que parto de la premisa de
que ningún político es el mesías
No obstante, a Saakashvili no le tembló la
mano y la reformas introdujeron más
libertad y más competitividad y
prosperidad en Georgia y eso me parece
fundamental, yo reconozco que soy un admirador de Saakashvili y sobre todo creo que el futuro
de Georgia es muy prometedor
Es decir, si el gobierno mantiene la
agenda de competitividad, de libre
mercado desarrollo de sectores en la
economía que implantó Saakashvili
me parece que Georgia va a dar mucho de
qué hablar y va a ser en pocos años
una los países de moda
Bueno, por algo lo habrán fichado en Ucrania
Desde luego Enrique, lo que habrá que hacer es esperar para ver
si la historia de Georgia acaba siendo tan
prometedora como puede parecer o no
Desde luego estaremos nosotros atentos a la actualidad que desde allí nos llega
Si tenéis algún comentario, si tienes cualquier aportación que realizar por favor no
dudéis en hacerlo, si bueno,
desgraciadamente Shevardnadze ya no se encuentra entre
nosotros pero bueno si.. Tiene una nieta
que es periodista en RT
Si quiere hacernos cualquier aclaración la
recibiremos con mucho gusto
Un saludo y hasta el próximo vídeo